hey howdy folks i'm here with
straight shooting cowboy from the south
cinema toast
i'm glad to be here thanks for having me
partner
today we're looking at the hillbilly
cheapskate shoot people
shoot man i'm so excited to introduce
you to this american culture here this
is gonna be
so this is perfect because you're a
hillbilly and i'm a cheapskate so this
works out
perfectly this is our love trial right
here
so you you've already seen this yeah
i've already seen this
you can guide me through this beauty oh
yeah i'll tell you first off
just the screen right here you got the
the old trailer with the car from the
90s
out in the woods somewhere probably on
the grandma's property so they can you
know
get all you know get some of her
internet that's smart that's smart ken
that's how you be a cheap leach off your
grandma as much as you can kids
is that it is that him yeah i don't see
this
ew look at that water what the [ __ ] is
that
how many times have they used that water
all about it don't you worry
oh this is the thing with cheapskates
it's like
[ __ ] i get trying to save money but when
you're compensating for like
[ __ ] grotesqueness it's just like
stop oh my goodness looks like you had a
good time you smell
good i don't think so
i don't believe a word of that how old
is he
he can't wrap himself in a [ __ ] towel
with his face gotta save money together
mama's gonna wrap him in the towel you
know ah
oh god go find your dad if i can get
something for free i'd rather do that
any
time than the same
what is that olive oil and bacon soda
why why i gotta say that i'm stupid
they don't you uh you smell good she
said he smelled good
she smells like olive oil yeah
he's like throwing the dirty water on
his face right now too like don't watch
your video watch your face anywhere else
go to the public bathroom
my family and i are so cheap that we all
share one type of water a day
we don't have cooties that is not one
what are they
they fill the tub up one time that's it
that is
that is not what that's a week worth of
gunk i saw that [ __ ]
that fouls that foul [ __ ]
look look at the light she's using two
like a little rechargeable
is that cheaper than just using your
electricity at home like what is this
oh it's a solar one maybe that's
probably it
it better because otherwise you're dumb
can you imagine that cold
gunk [ __ ] water dude i've taken cold
like
cold showers before like no hot water oh
yeah oh this makes your whole life body
just
crinkle up and she's over there just
sitting in it i mean
it's supposed to be good for you ken
that's good for immune system
immune immune system
look at this woman ken you can tell
she's fresh as a fresh towel that she
uses
she is the epitome of health right here
this lady's got the strongest immune
system
she's got to have it to be taking a bath
in that water
sometimes i actually do want to take my
own shower here and there
as you deserve brandon you deserve to
not share the bath water
with your mother i guess he goes first
does he goes first that was what the
water looked like when he goes first i
don't think he does i think i think they
have a hierarchy of like
bad bathing i ain't going oh
got the water ready for you it's all
nice and warm you know
uh you know i'm trying to save on the
toilet water too so went ahead and just
took a huge dump in it
okay want to save the toilet water
okay just so we're clear we're not
making fun of poor people here this is
people that have money but they just
want to save
any bit they can which i think is
different yeah
definitely is you want to take my own
shower here and there
i can't really do much because my
parents like to save water
think about how much water a bathtub
uses i bet there's probably
don't take a bath don't have to take a
bed you can take a shower
i know how much water comes from a
shower because i sometimes i
plug the shower thing in the bathtub and
then i like to sit in the water that's
remaining all right
not that much are you telling me that
you you plug the you plug it up you
shower
i shower i plug it up and then i sit and
it barely fills up my legs
barely so are you doing the same thing
that they're doing you're just sitting
back it's just fun it's just fun because
i don't have a [ __ ] seat in my shower
mr fans who paints over there all right
i gotta i gotta work with what i got all
right
wash yourself off and all that filth is
in the bottom of your tub and then you
sit in it is that what you said you do
it does not look like [ __ ] this all
right it does not look like that let me
tell you it's clear
look crystal clear you've told me the
story of you pewdiepie
no i never pooped in the shower
i never did that i didn't have a choice
ken
i didn't have a choice did you talk
about that story again or something
because a lot of people are talking
about it now
no everyone's just referencing because
they think it's funny and it's not funny
it was traumatic
i had no control i thought it was a
toilet
they didn't who puts yeah it was a
camping site
they had locks on the showers and i
thought it was a
toilet i was poisoned
i thought the story you told me you were
like at a party or something and then
yeah i was poisoned at the party and
then you just yes
you were like i'm just gonna have to
poop in the shower i got no choice and
you did
all right you're making me tell this
story again okay listen
i i haven't heard this in years okay i
need to hear the whole thing again
i was poisoned at a party we had
i don't know what it's called when
everyone brings a different type of meal
to a party a potluck
pot luck yeah uh yeah that was that
someone said hey felix why don't you try
the sauce and i'm like
oh absolutely
that was a trap okay a few hours later
we're at the dance floor everyone's
having fun but my stomach is telling me
there's an emergency about to happen
i run i run ken to the campsite that was
nearby
and there was a whole [ __ ] line to
the toilet yeah yeah and i literally
i went and said this is an emergency
i need to go that's how bad it was i'm
swedish i would never tell anyone that
and i literally all the doors i dragged
all the doors
i didn't ignored what everyone said i
just like all right opening all the
doors they were all locked
i rush inside everywhere i finally find
a door
that has a lock on it i'm like bingo
it's coming now whether i like it or not
but i found the toilet open the door
it's a shower
my [ __ ] had already made up its mind
there was no turning back at that point
okay i had no choice
can't believe it
the part where they found it and they
talked about it later
and you were like what who would do that
i ended up getting a job at that
campsite a few years later
and they still told literally years
later
and they told the story of the great
tale of this
foul demon that did such awful things
and then they have to clean it up but
i'm just sitting there like
i can't believe you had to do that who
would do such a thing
that makes the story so good is that
they they
talk about it who would do this
maybe i'm putting locks on the showers i
just pour
about that much in there oh that's
enough for my
or you just pour it in your hand like a
normal human being what you need to hear
what she says about this that's not
that's not just for her that's
no everybody's out of luck so
everybody's really good about rationing
by rationing her family's use of soap
and shampoo
melody manages to keep bottles for over
six months
in fact
they use like the amount of shampoo that
i put in my hair a day i barely have any
hair
it's for three people and i like that we
have to ration it because if you're out
then you're out of luck
so you're basically saying that the last
person to take a shower is fun
that's their son and he has to take a
bath in the dirty water
for brandon save on almost all of their
household supplies
i don't buy toilet paper i use newspaper
what do you do not
you do not wipe your ass with a hat that
is not human
no what that is that is like housing
brochures
household supplies i don't buy no you do
not that is not going to work
think about that is not just because
it's paper doesn't mean you can
ah i'm so glad we're watching this video
together
[Music]
imagine your poor pooper after you get
that paper cut from that gene
oh brandon get out of that house brandon
that's not over yet i mean i i'm stuck
on this cat i can't
you gotta see the rest of it i'm telling
you dude i can't go
up again i can't do it man pull it paper
i use newspapers that we get free in
town
one sheet don't need more than that do
not crinkle it she crinkles that
you're the one you know i would not
crinkle it
do not i was really thinking there's no
way she's crinkling that
the most horrific thing a horrific thing
in my mind always she does
the worst thing i can think of she dies
she's a demon how do you even you don't
even wipe yourself with that you
literally gotta scrape
your butthole that's gotta be so painful
oh my god dude i would not wipe then
i would just not wipe that's probably
why the bath is that color
forgive me i can't wash this [ __ ]
[Music]
it doesn't flush into this bag
oh okay i can't do it dude i'm so glad
you let me pick today's video this
she picks us every time every time she
shocks me to something else she pulls
out the [ __ ] bag
newspaper all right we gotta get through
this
it is full it is full it is full it's
full
i would put two macs in there i'm not
gonna do this one because i haven't used
it i don't know why i'm entertaining
this as a logical thing like
oh god i've had people say here let me
buy your role
wait she oh she took it back okay i
thought she took the poop back
she took the example one out because you
want to waste
it i don't understand this toilet paper
thing if you really don't want to pay
for a toilet paper just go to a [ __ ]
cafe and pull out right
yeah starbucks or something you know
yes holy [ __ ] if i was brandon at least
i would do that i'm
gonna keep can you imagine having to
keep your own secret stash
secret stash of napkins from your mother
that wipes her ass
otherwise she makes you wipe your ass
with newspapers
she she goes she goes through the [ __ ]
banging me like brandon
what is this tissue here what is this
what
the [ __ ] is this brandon explain why are
you using this fancy ass
we don't do that in that house brandon
let me buy your roll of toilet paper
it's not that i yes yes
can't buy a roller toilet i just prefer
the wiping my ass with newspaper
is that what she's going to say what is
she going to say i never know i don't
need to we don't need it
now sometimes
look dude it's not over all right
there's more it's just a sadist she's
satan
look at this she's okay i come in here i
got boys in the family they don't always
replace newspapers i've insulated this
window
with newspapers keeps the light on it
helps with heating and cooling
and saves me if i'm on the toilet and i
need something i could just lift this
window
and there's me some more toilet paper
she has a secret stash
she's keeping the secret stash in her
window
for insulation she has a newspaper
for installation that she can wipe her
butt with in case
that's that's smart that's double usage
i respect that that's big brain
we try to keep our electric bill as low
as possible by making sure the lights
are not being used
we do have electricity see it's on
that's it but you don't use it so why
what's the point
she walks around the house with this
lantern like she's playing like some
survival horror video game
yes this is the house this is super
beach
i don't even want to know what the
kitchen looks like i like when she
showed the lights
but like look we have electricity it's
on that's enough
that's quite enough i'm not going to
waste any more i we have electricity in
this house
i don't use it i use a lantern i'm not
going to run up no 100
electric bill that to me sometimes makes
me have a heart attack is that
electricity expensive in america because
that the price varies a lot with
countries i have a pretty big house i
have computers that are always running i
got lights on right now
my power bill is like 200 a month 200
yeah
for a big house and computers always
running it yeah and like my whole family
so that's pretty cheap
literally leaves every freaking light in
the house owned constantly and i have to
go through and be like all right
i can wash a laundry basket full of
dirty clothes
as fast as a electric washing machine
some say he's the fastest clothes washer
in the west
oh she's gonna watch this wash your face
i mean a washing machine sometimes takes
hours but the point is that you don't
want to spend that time it's
like it smells in the dirt out
[Music]
looks like i got all the soap out of it
squeeze out the red one the red one's
clean
right again i can do it as fast there's
four people doing it
[Laughter]
it's something we enjoy doing as a
family and it gets us out doing
something together there's no reason to
waste our money
on the other staff by doing her laundry
room
melody saved herself two thousand
dollars on a washing machine and she
also uses her back
washing machine does not cost two
thousand dollars that's what i say every
time i watch some of these things
they're like
they saved 40 million dollars by
[Music]
yeah exactly and you can get a used one
for even cheaper
they always do that and they give the
most maximum amount and be like look how
yeah exactly how much money i [ __ ]
say there was a one
family that refused to get furniture
because they're like sometimes that can
cost like thirty thousand dollars
is that the one where they borrowed
their neighbors first yeah yeah yeah
exactly
what the [ __ ] was that
oh my god i love the show you can get
used furniture
you don't have to pay thirty thousand oh
my god look how much money i saved up
to save on the cost of another appliance
we had a
small uh chest freezer that went out and
instead of just floating away we just
when we come up with the idea of burying
it in the ground
we got some eggs this here is some
hey man
that looks freaking nasty dude that's
definitely gonna be good for you don't
you worry about that
wait until they get sick and have to pay
medical bills like what are you going to
do then
hey at least they're self-sustained ken
yeah well hey i'm sure they probably got
ways to get past medical bills too they
probably got some home remedies and
stuff
yeah doctor just google it
home butcher pig apple pie moonshine
the great apple pie moonshine what the
[ __ ]
get that moonshine with the with the raw
meat hey i got some eggs and some
salmonella in there heck yeah we're
gonna have a party
[Laughter]
right next to all this trash dude thing
about this refrigerator doesn't cost a
dime to uh run this
you get 100 degrees outside if this is
in the sun that's no good you have to
keep it in the shade
but the ground keeps it at about 55
degrees inside
i'm sorry i gotta investigate yeah go
ahead investigate this
this is what i was thinking about too
it's 12 degrees uh-huh yeah you should
look up like what the uh
recommended yeah temperature yeah
exactly i know because i worked at a
shitty fast food restaurant it had
bacteria easily
lives in this temperature i don't
remember exactly but it's like
like i worked in a meat cutting
department and like the meat room itself
was like 40 degrees which is even colder
than that and that's where we like
prepared it
celsius please the point the point is
that will definitely not help
12 that's not enough and he gave the
best number he could think of right
they will last probably a month or more
oh i definitely see why some people see
our behaviors as over the top but
i don't care about being normal just
gave us kids some moonshine
i didn't know this apple pie moonshine
boy
that's how i get through my days
[Music]
numbs to pay him for the bath let me
tell you they're wiping my butt with
that
crinkly toilet paper i don't even feel
the pain anymore my [ __ ]
is in 50 pieces but i don't feel a
goddamn thing after a couple days
i think my parents are a little obsessed
with the
brandon run get out brandon please save
yourself after a while just became a
challenge and say hey let's see how much
we can save this week and
most extreme thing i ever did to save on
medical costs or any kind of costs like
that
oh here we go my own teeth if i have a
cavity i just take a little
chisel and a hammer and i sit there and
chip it and chip it and chip it until i
can knock it out
every once i've i've been known to take
it wacky really hard you get knocked out
for a minute you come to and you finish
what
she said she passed out from doing it as
well
she knocked herself out woke back up and
finished
god damn
she's she's a demon i stand by
you knew that she just called it out
what the [ __ ] is that
look at this huh ron brandon
he's like i broke my arm well all we got
to do is really
put a belt around it and get a saw and
some
apple pie moonshine and take care of
that sucker right quick
take it i am super excited to see my new
grandchild
but that's five more people that i'm
used to that's five more people
using our electric oh i would not eat a
goddamn thing from that house
can you imagine she's her daughter's
coming so her daughter's escaped she's
gotten out
but now oh why would your whole family
come and stay with you when you live
like this
oh i would not exactly
oh i can't wait to see this people using
her water five more mouths to feed
i she's already bitching about it
how did this happen then yeah it's just
a huge deal
we have a 72 foot trailer and i would
say half of it is closed off
what the f did she do with the other
half they don't need it
we all share them why why you have it
it costs nothing
that makes no sense on space
it's already small this one oh the house
we blocked off to save on heating and
cooling
heating and cooling yeah it looks pretty
it looks pretty decent
four of us sleeping here on this king
side they don't use any anyway right
what ah that's bad what are those
branding oh
there's another son there he hadn't said
anything he's like
[Laughter]
i do have two other bedrooms but i am
not willing to
to use that part of my house i'm not
going to do that we're going to have to
figure out
another place for her to sleep that's
not going to cost us any money
[Music]
i like how they could get natural
sunlight in their house but they boarded
off all the
windows [ __ ]
magazines so she walked around with this
[ __ ] lantern
oh my god i mean i don't know how do you
even like make those other babies like
her kids are just in the bed over there
with her and they're like all right
honey it's time to
get frisky
[Music]
i don't know i don't know how to go
there
for her family of four it's more than
enough money but adding any further
expenses could throw off her finances
entirely
my daughter called and she's coming to
stay for two weeks
i do have two other bedrooms but i am
not willing to
to use that part of my house i'm setting
up this tent for me and my family to
sleep in
what you gonna set up a tent for him and
his family to sleep in while they have
visited she did
she doesn't compromise whatsoever with
her family coming over she has space for
them
but they have to sleep in i mean i'd
take the tent to be honest
i'll gladly take the tank the room is
probably by the
crap bag bathroom yeah like what my
daughter and her husband and kids can
sleep in the house
we've done this before so it's not a big
deal why are they subtitling him i can
hear him
what the [ __ ] he's got that southern
he's got him
my family yeah three months
before i don't understand a single word
he's saying ken i don't know
thank god for the subtitles got shut up
people were acting like oh my gosh she
lives in a tent for three months these
are the same people who go pay
to stay at a resort they may they're
staying for three months
i think last time they came over so they
said well why don't you just open the
rest of our house up
you know you have to get to pay for
anything open your house up
three months
home sweet home for the next two weeks
okay two weeks thank god my daughter's
lifestyle is
very different from ours i think
anyone's lifestyle is different from
yours
yeah and she's she's wasteful we use
cold water
but my daughter has to have hot water so
we're gonna have to figure a way to heat
it
fancy daughter from the city she's
coming over here
she probably watch your bird's real
toilet i bet that dumb [ __ ]
brought toilet paper do you think
she allows him to flush you know she
ain't landing them flush kim
you know there's another video where a
dude only flushes once a week oh
of course
yeah i see poop oh yeah you got
roommates and everything
[Music]
we got to find that old horse trough
okay brandy's not going to take a bath
in our bath water
and you know her honey after four of us
she acts like everyone else is crazy
why is she going to take a bath in i
understand i
don't get it man what's wrong with that
bathwater it has a big hole in the
bottom
probably line this with plastic wait
wait
wait a minute what the [ __ ] is that what
the [ __ ] is that ken
is that their bathtub uh it's gonna be
they gotta heat it up somehow too maybe
we're gonna have some uh
some people soup coming up let's check
it out no
okay
nice i really think what we need to do
is boil some water on a campfire so i'm
not using my electricity from my stove
[Music]
look who's coming yeah
yeah buddy
he's precious grandma gets to hold him
i'm your new grandma fanny is hi
hey hey they have another bathtub right
there
what's the problem there's so much if
you look in the background while this
video is
like there's so much junk yet
damn wow me my mom are nothing alike
i'm like a city girl she is a country
girl
look over on your left see the tent
that's where we're gonna stay
they have a baby too that makes it kind
of like what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] we would never go that far to
save a dollar i got a big surprise for
you i know how you love taking hot baths
and stuff
we got you a nice hot bath outside for
y'all tank we've been boiling water
see we're trying to accommodate you
where you'll be happy
yeah don't you like it put his feet in
there he can take a nice bath dip him in
there let him see
it'll be okay oh she's doing it
see he'll lie what they weren't always
that extreme they used to like just
what the [ __ ] is happening like no
no no look at the child he knows
get me out the dude the husband's back
there's like oh my god please give me
your name
yeah what do you do the one you're
dating is like oh we need to
visit my mom's house oh oh
we can just visit for like a day and
we'll go stay in the hotel how about
that
yeah do little stuff but
all of a sudden it kind of got extreme
it's just kind of like almost a
contest to see how much money they can
save that'll keep it going the whole
time for you and there's a pot
you need more hot water you just dip it
out dip it up in there boil it
with a diaper yeah she she knew is that
a thing
no like what the [ __ ] i don't know one
thing
i don't know what that was baby in there
with the diaper because now this diaper
is going to
absorb all that water and they're going
to change it what the [ __ ]
[Music]
boys had a couple squirrels earlier some
squirrel dumplings
is that what you eat ken squirrel
dumplings you know let's go out in the
woods and shoot down a couple squirrels
and you know just to pry them up and fry
them pan outside
pick up trucks and eat them too it's
delicious
those are frog legs on there too hell
oh man
you get it for free you gotta be happy i
can't wait you'll be
happy oh my god man
i can't do i'm like this video shocked
me so hard already like i don't even
know
[Music]
look how party didn't look girl
are you going to be sick
look at that him like no
why is she calling it dumplings you say
dipped in oh
oh i just realized what it is
you see can i am a pescetarian
i would never eat a squirrel
that is foul poor squirrel
the soul of the squirrel the baby likes
it she's
after grandma's own heart i like have
some pools to play
guinea pig we got to try that sometime
[Music]
i highly doubt my parents will ever
change their cheapskate ways now that
they've
adapted to it i don't think there's a
limit at all to how far i'll go to save
money
well clearly obviously i don't think
anyone doubts you on that
holy f ken well thank you for showing me
that
you feel so bad for the sun yeah oh man
at least we know where the water is
brought yeah all right ken
god bless you check out ken everyone
subscribe for more epic videos every
subscriber i get one more subscriber
let's get it i feel sick
man